They need an easy API to access everything.
Imagine this agent negotiating contracts over email.
Probably not the most effective way.
So actually last week as well,
we launched the agentic marketplace.
Really building on the idea of Intents.
The Intent is really the outcome you want to achieve.
You can say like,
hey, I want this website to be built.
I want this building to be constructed.
You can send it to this Intent engine
or the matching book
and then other agents can come in
and say, cool.
I'll actually do it for this much.
It will take this long.
Here's the requirements.
Agreement carries the conditions
and so you can actually have this agreement
have the funds escrowed, do the work,
and then resolve it.